subia muito e etapa foi muito boa todos
pessoal de quem fala dar que exige muito
bem vindos a mais um e hoje o pessoal
nós vamos fazer uma coisa que você já
vem há muito tempo hoje nós vamos
resistir é vídeos neste caso gift
imagens nojentas enquanto como eu já
tinha feito um vídeo deste gênero está
aqui pra quem não viu eo quase metade
nesse vídeo é porque é muito nojento
vocês comerem enquanto existem essas
coisas e pessoas o menu tereré metal
então vamos lá ver se eu consigo
aguentar comer um menu tudo enquanto
esses chips vocês quiserem fazer esse
desafio comigo vão lá pegar uma sandes
de pão com manteiga ou qualquer coisa
que vocês possam comer ela na cozinha
volta em que provemos de assistir juntos
e estigmas que não se esteja a assistir
geeks porque os comportamentos são
imagens mas é mais ingênuo ou encontrei
que um site supostamente com 20 imagens
nojentas confira 20 imagens mais
brilhantes já colocadas na internet
ai meu deus jogos já que uma batata só
pra lá os tiros livres em 32 um bar para
limpar o irã bem direitinho sua pobre eu
nunca fui assim mas conseguiu marcar o
segundo
curioso a rússia e outros oito foram
empurrou para dentro como ao blog isso é
curioso eu não queria fazer isso já
partiu o braço dói muito até agora está
a ser fácil para a próxima uma invasão
estava sendo que em aranhas são muito
estranhas
meu deus e agora imagine um lindo este
também então vamos continuar quarta
imagem quarto game mas o que é isso que
eu acho que isso é uma espécie de um
bicho extra em tela mas não só ainda não
vai me vendo como é como o mj essa
espécie de sapos sabe sai das costas da
mãe
o que é isso é nojento mas não é tão
tolo desemprego está próximo este foi o
fim da picada a este mas sim eu pude
orgulho é muito nojento cujo agora isso
deve ir para a próxima imagem essa nova
legenda 8 acho que dizer que é louco é
pouco à vontade em 1 a 1
a imagem embora lá loucura não perguntou
o que acontece quando você chuta uma
parede com um palito de dentro basta uma
do seu pé e ao bater o pleito
op você vê na imagem vulgar calma
momentânea ou comer um não é tão não é
tão nojenta zin próxima imagem a essa
queda de neve no b eu acho que nosso
carro é mais um problema no nosso modelo
é hoje uma marca próxima imagem ganhou
um olho com uma lágrima é só isso
isso é nojento é fácil é para a próxima
como será que os pregos foi parar ei de
um prego naturista como é que algum dia
tirar o prego na cabeça no futebol pra
todo lado de paulo scola converteu
metade dos sócios é uma próxima imagem
como fica absurdo depois de uma sessão
de implante de pêlos no peito
completamente o contrário diz que o
estúdio do pai todos olham com cara de
nerd diz a aiê para quem não sabe que a
gente serve para colocar as coisas nos
postiços e ela ficou com os exames dela
originais no velhinho
agora a próxima imagem vem caindo da
manhã até o lento
foi isso o que eu tenho e mandar seu
time com 10
vem cá e dá um beijinho pedra pronto
pode vir em uma larva
eu tenho uma vallim não perceber ainda
talvez na próxima próxima na cara não
está bem não passa para o fazer isso eu
tenho que fazer esse desafio
o músico é que já teve uma quebra 50
embaixo eu nunca vi que eu acho que esta
é a última aí vem uma folha da tarde e
há muito não tem muita agonia vai abrir
agora não é muito fã
eu acho que esse é o último grito deste
povo para lá só para a próxima página
como em baixo número que vocês acharam
foi mais nojento só acho que o mais
difícil foi mesmo 16
agora não sei o que é aquilo eu acho que
o problema é que a bola passou à próxima
página o título é preciso y gente que
você nunca mais vai querer ver vamos
saber se sempre para a gestão começa já
eu tenho contrato é assim gosta da minha
pistola
[Música]
isso aqui é só com os olhos na legenda
joga saibam que fica limpo
ganha o primeiro
a água que os colocaram um sabão em cima
da minhoca
aí ela estava em andamento em mim é
alguém isso não gente oil da primeira
111 lapa comércio josé
o twitter é um milagre do investimento
vamos lá ver e isso enquanto tem
qualquer coisa a ver com barato eu já
saí eu tinha certeza agora 31 vai lá que
é barata olha aí continuar barato disse
nurrohman tema lula e isso tem muito
barata 123456 é próximo de me deixe
quieto oi 31
embora nenhum bicho é desta que o bicho
é uma testa em podendo comer dá pra
comer fora próximo um pequeno incômodo
no olho esclarecido isso é seguro
sentido agora 31 vai pleitear uma
minhoca no olho que ela está em busca de
comida fora do olho
embora próximo e para por favor aí tem
aranha caminhada já fez isso inclusive é
é muito bonito só os quiserem ver como é
que funciona a mudança de casca danny
ter ampla parcela no vídeo lá vocês
podem ver na perfeição a cair embora
próximo que só porque as mulheres é um
dos primeiros filmes do namorado e em
outras linhas só estão prontos estão
prontos 31 vai perder muito sangue
eu acho que isso aqui como já comigo e
não consegui engolir o que tem dentro da
boca
só temos 17 uma foto mais 78 uma vez só
isso
agora próxima próxima vai saber se
avança com estão nazaré esta vai ser
pior vai cair a qualquer coisa do muricy
eu vou dar uma dentada bola foi o eye to
eye tamanho próximo game para abrir o
apetite ok uma piso cheio de baratas
agora é um galo pisco tem proteína não é
muito dinheiro não próximo que foi é o
título do livro
esta primeira vista e banho genta só
depois quando você começou a ver e
percebem que a montagem não é assim tão
nojento né nunca diga que não tem nada
pra comer a enumerar lyons primeira
mulher que vai explodir dentro da boca
não é muito homogêneo mas vamos ver
agora 3 um pai tirano 111 mil
não só eu como o bicho estranho
encontrar um livro chamado o que é isso
de seu entendimento entre os dois um em
qualquer coisa linda vaga
acho que é uma barriga né é só isto
então o próximo e último gif então vamos
aproveitar desculpa mas não estou indo
muito bem
ae 3219 uma barata entrar ele imagina
não é muita gente num ano que segundo
ele vai conseguir mas as pessoas já
sabem se quiserem ver mais vídeos deste
gênero união como vários elementos
desses tiros no juventus me têm muito em
baixo não foi inscrito no canal
inscrevam-se deixei muito na equipe
neste vídeo por favor peço que vocês não
deixassem lá que vai parecer uma barata
dentro do assunto é mesmo igual àquela
época porque era uma coisa pra vocês
todos eles sofrem um estado fiquem bem
até a próxima
[Música]